[AUDIO LOGO]
- Hi, everybody. Welcome to
the Data Science Hangout.
Happy December, everybody.
If this is your first
time joining us today,
so nice to meet you.
I'm Rachael. I lead
customer marketing at Posit.
If it is your
first Data Science Hangout today,
I encourage you to
say hi in the chat,
so we can all
welcome you in here--
to anybody joining for
the first time too.
The Hangout is our open space
to chat about data science
leadership, questions
you're facing,
and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of
data across
different industries.
So we're here every Thursday
at the same time, same place,
unless it's a holiday.
But if you're watching
this recording on YouTube later,
the link to add it to your
calendar will be in the details
below as well.
We're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everyone. So we love to
hear from everybody no matter your
years of experience, titles,
industry, or languages
that you work in.
It's totally OK to just listen
in here if you want or maybe
you're out on a walk
or on a lunch break,
or whatever time of
day it is for you.
But there's always three
ways you can jump in and ask
questions or provide
your own perspective too.
So you can raise
your hand on Zoom,
and I'll keep my eye out here.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And if it's something you want
me to read out loud instead,
just put a little star next to
it or asterisk, so that I know.
And then lastly, we
do have a Slido link,
where you can ask
questions anonymously too.
And our co-hosts here in
the background will share that.
Just another quick note. I
forgot to say this sometimes.
But I love to see the
conversation that happens in
the chat during the hangout.
It's so cool to see
all the resources that are shared
there. So I encourage you to
use the chat during the hangout
as well and share all that you
want there. It's fun to
read through it later.
But I'm so excited to be
joined by my co-host today Matt MacDonald,
senior managing director at Kroll
Bond Rating Agency. And, Matt,
I'd love to have you
kick it off with introducing yourself
and maybe sharing a little
bit about your role and something
you like to do outside of work.
- Oh, OK, yeah. So I
need to for business purposes make the
following statement. So we'll
get through this quickly.
So the views and opinions
expressed during this
presentation are mine and
do not necessarily reflect the
views or positions of KBRA
and its affiliates. So
that's what's going on here.
All right. So thanks
so much Rachael,
and thanks to everybody
for joining today.
And thanks to Posit for hosting
the Data Science Hangout.
So my name is
Matt McDonald. And
I live in Stamford, Connecticut
with my wife and daughters. And
I tell people I'm a statistician
when they ask me what I do.
And I've been involved in
data science for quite some time,
coming up on 20
years, I would say.
I work for Kroll
Bond Rating Agency.
So I think we've
rebranded recently,
so we are now known as
just KBRA, I would say. And
so what does KBRA do? So
we provide credit opinions.
So we're a financial
services company providing credit opinions
in the form of credit
ratings. We've been around since 2010.
So we are a
post-financial crisis credit rating agency.
And our
competitors are companies like
Moody's, S&amp;P, and Fitch.
So these are companies
you may have heard of.
I've been at KBRA since 2015,
so I just surpassed my eight
year anniversary, so I've
been here for quite some time.
And when I started here, I was
in charge of model risk
management, which is something
that if you're in the financial
services or if you
work for a bank,
it might be something
that you're familiar with.
I don't know how
widely known it is
outside of financial services.
But there's a need because
a lot of these companies that
I've worked for in the past
and that I work for now are
regulated. There's a need
for controls on the model.
So we have people who are
dedicated not to building the
models, but
evaluating the models.
So I started my
career here at KBRA
in the model risk management
space. I sort of created that
framework and rolled it out in the company.
And now I'm in charge
of the quantitative modeling group.
So now I'm sort of on the
other side of the fence. And
I'm in charge of
building the model.
So I run
a small team of
data scientists,
econometricians, statisticians,
financial modelers.
And our job is to provide models
to
credit analysts. So
these are models that
these people that are used
in the credit rating process.
And
you can group them
into a small--
you can categorize them.
So a lot of them are like
statistical models. You can
think about classification models,
logistic regression
type approach.
And other ones are like
stress testing models.
So
lots of times we'll be looking
at scenarios that could
happen, but are bad
and plausible.
And we want to get a sense
of what would happen to
some financial portfolio or
something along those lines,
right? So we're looking to
see when things get bad,
how bad will things get.
And how does that translate
into our analysis of the credit.
Sometimes we get engaged to
help people
develop
these scenarios, like what
would an adverse scenario for
interest rates look like?
And we get involved in that.
And then there's sort of
cats and dogs type stuff
around data analysis.
So we'll be drawn in and
engaged to help people analyze
sometimes large data sets,
sometimes not large data sets.
I'd say that we're not really
in the huge data space.
We're kind of dealing with data
sets that fit into CSV files
that we can look at, right?
So that's kind of what we're
doing. Those are the types
of models we're doing.
I realized that in
as I was describing this talk,
I think I might have said
it's about team building.
And I'm not really going
to talk too much about team
building. I mean,
you might see that I'm reading
some notes here, so I'm trying
to have some structure
to what I'm doing here.
But I mean,
as far as team building
goes, I always follow the
guidance of hire
people who are good
and are talented and that you
like to spend time with. And
so far, I've been quite
lucky, so I have that largely
where I am right
now. So that's good.
- What about something you
like to do outside of work too?
- Oh, yeah. So I
play guitar. And
actually, I haven't picked
it up a whole lot recently.
But once in a while,
I'll do an open mic type setting
type of a thing. So that's fun.
What's that?
- There's lots of
musicians in here.
- Oh, nice. We should start
like a jam session someday at
Posit Data Science
Hangout jam session.
Yeah. Don't rely on
me for singing though.
I do it only out of necessity.
- So Aaron asks what kind
of music do you play?
- Oh, so I mean, I'm kind
of more of a classic rock guy. But
I don't really have the luxury
of playing the music I like to
play. It's more of I'm
limited to what I can play.
So three chords
are pretty good.
Singing talent, never
stop Bob Dylan. Nice.
- One other fun
question before we--
they're all fun questions,
but funny question. Last week,
there were a bunch of people
in the chat commenting on their
favorite or worst office
jargon like boil the ocean or--
- Oh, yeah.
- --do you have a
favorite or pet peeve one?
- No, I mean,
it's like a bit ephemeral,
like I'll hear it and I'll just
shake my head and say like, oh,
but then I let it go. That's
one of the things. It's
survival skill 101. Let things
go. You can't carry them around.
I will say that sometimes you'll hear
someone use a noun as a verb,
so when there's a perfectly
good verb out there to be used.
So someone will say like,
we need to solution this problem
and that kind of rubs
me the wrong way a lot.
There's a word called solve that
would work perfectly fine right there.
- So funny. Well,
I just was getting people going
with that in the chat there. But,
Matt,
for some of us that are
not in the financial space or maybe
familiar with credit
rating agencies,
would you be able to just
walk us through an example project
or something that your team
might be building a model for?
You don't have to get
too into the specifics.
- Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, I can't--
I saw a comment in here about
a particular rating that
was issued by KBRA. I
can't really get into that.
I was not in--
I was not directly
involved with that.
One of my models may have been
employed for that.
But that's one of the things
that we don't really--
we're
a step away from that ground level.
So we'll build a model
that's available for people to use.
And part of our challenge
is to ensure that people
understand its limitations
and understand when it--
and when and when it
should not be used,
is when it should and
should not be used. I mean,
we've put a lot of thought into
how we get things out into
the world. And we're starting to gel
around
like a playbook that we employ.
So
I'll give just a theoretical
example of a model we might
build. Let's say we wanted to
build a model that would give a
probability of default--
a classification model.
So that would be like, OK,
we're going to go
collect data on some
on corporates or maybe banks
or something like that.
And we'll think about what
types of things might be
driving default, right,
and then we'll perform
a statistical analysis,
and we'll build a model.
And maybe that would be like
the simplest, simplest thing,
a logistic regression model.
So if you tell me a company's--
some things on
their balance sheet,
something about their cash flow
and that type of stuff,
then maybe we could build
a model that would help you
figure out if that
entity will default.
I mean, that's really
half the battle.
And that's a huge battle
because, like I said, we're
regulated, and we have
internal controls who are
evaluating our work.
So we need to really
make sure that all
of our work is
repeatable and transparent and inspectable,
and we can explain it. And
it's well-documented. And then
we have the expectation
that there's evidence-based.
So we perform back testing
and we present that.
But the
next problem--
and this is when
I say playbook,
I'm talking about
is how do we make--
once that model has
been built, how do we allow
that model to be used by
people, by real people
who are doing a job?
And we are--
I mean shameless plug for Posit,
so we use the Posit, team's platform.
So that allows us to do
our work in a common environment.
And we have
controls in place that help
us make things repeatable.
We're using Git,
we're using RN.
If we're building an R
then we're making sure that our
environments are sort of repeat--
we can build them
up. And then we are--
I mean, we're not 100% there,
but we've been experimenting
with things like Vetiver and
plumber for deploying
models via API that
are then usable by people.
One of the things that we
have been really working on and
really focusing on is like establishing
ourselves. I mean,
the conundrum that we have
is that we're a small team,
and we kind of sit between
a technology organization,
we're building software and
credit analysts who are doing
the work of credit analysis.
So like the tool kits between
those two folks and between us are
radically different.
I would say the analysts
are largely using Microsoft Excel
for a lot of their work, the
technology folks are
using Python mostly for--
like in a software
development context. And
I'm an advocate of using the
right tool for the job so we're
using Python and R in more of a
scripting context to
do our analysis and
build our model.
So
being able to talk to
all of those different parties has
been something that we've
been really working on.
And we've had a
lot of success with
the tools that we've chosen in making--
breaking down some of the
barriers that we face.
-
Can you expand upon that a bit
maybe for some of us who are having--
who are kind of in the
middle of that right now?
How do you break down
some of those barriers between teams?
- Yeah, I mean, it's like--
it's a balancing act,
I would say, between
reaching out to people and
operating on their turf.
We're talking their language
but also working very hard
to retain some sort of
line
of ownership of things. So
I would say like when
we do deploy an API,
we've had some success and
done some experimentation with
providing people
with some code,
PBA code in their Excel
spreadsheet to call our API so
that they don't need to learn--
really learn a new
skill to use our work.
And going the other way,
some of our projects,
some of our models
are not really that
regression-based model where
all I have is a set of data
and I'm going to create a
prediction. Some of them are
really more software type
models. They're
more complicated.
These are like
simulation models,
Monte Carlo simulations
where we're going to--
that's a pretty standard
and credit risk modeling,
like a pretty
standard approach.
And so you need to build
software to do that.
And when we--
I want to--
I don't want to build,
own, and maintain software.
That's sort of a job unto
itself. So we do engage with
technology, and that's
like when we go there,
we've sort of decided that they
really don't speak R so much so
we will have to do more
Python stuff. And switch our mindset
of how we're using Python
from that idea of performing some
analysis, writing a script
that does a thing into writing
Python code that
is integrated in like a
software development type of a project.
So
I'd say that we've been had
a lot of success with learning
the tools that are employed
by technology and trying to figure
out how we apply
those to our work. So
everybody on the team
has been learning Git,
we really are getting--
we're very good at Git.
And we find that Git is a super
useful tool not just for--
like I said earlier, we
need all of our work to be
repeatable because we could be
engaged by a whole bunch of
people who are asking us to
explain what we've done.
So Git is super
helpful for that.
All of our code is transparent,
inspectable. People can
see all the changes that
have happened over time.
But also we're using some
of the project management
tools that they have.
So things like Jira
and Wiki-based
documentation, things are--
we've had a lot
of success with.
- Thank you.
I see Julia you had a follow
up question here on the
repeatable work. Do
you want to jump in?
JULIA: Sure, thanks. This
is really interesting.
So you were just touching on
how your work needs to be like
replicable and transparent.
Does that extend also to your
models? Do your models need to
be explainable or is it OK
to use black box models as long
as the process to derive them
has been transparent in your industry?
- Yeah, no, I think that
there's no regulatory
need or sort of like
nothing dictating what kind of
algorithms we can use to build
our models. But I would say we
definitely stay on
the side of simpler,
maybe
slightly less
performative models
that are explainable.
Because it's more of like not only
do I have to explain it to
the credit analysts, but they
probably need to explain to
a lot of other people how they
arrived at their decision.
So if we have just an
absolute black box,
that doesn't really work for us.
Although we have used some of those
approaches to help us benchmark
our models. So when you
have like a matrix of
model performance and
interpretability, I
would say, would be
kind of a graph I've
seen in the past,
and we're kind of on
the interpretable end of the spectrum.
But
lots of times we'll
ask the question like,
what are we leaving on the
table as far as model performance
when we make that decision?
So we'll employ like a more black
box type approach to say like, look,
if we didn't care if we
could explain this to anybody ever,
what could we achieve?
And we use that in our
decision making process.
- Thank you. Andy, I see
you had a question a bit earlier.
Do you to jump in here? ANDY NUNEZ
BREWSTER: Sure. Thanks. Hi.
I'm Andy Nunez
Brewster. And my question was about the
looking ahead if you're using--
you did answer the
question actually--
you're using some simulation
model versus just data driven
exploration. And I was curious if
you're doing that in R or
what's the stack on that
side of the house. Thanks.
- Yeah.
Yeah, I would say like the--
we--
I mean, we use both Python
and R for our more backward
looking statistical data
driven models and then
those models that are
more simulation-based or
Monte Carlo type things
just simply because we are
eager to tap into some of
the good stuff that our technology
team has been building.
We're primarily--
if we're going to
be writing software,
aside from internal R
packages that are really--
like, my team is the
audience for those.
We're going to build a package that's
going to be help us do something.
We'll use R for that.
But if we're going to be
building software that's going to be deployed
across the company, then we'll
be looking to Python mostly.
We've been experimenting
with the very simple and
straightforward--
I think I've heard the term
microservice but I probably am misusing it,
like the idea of like I have
some data and I want to get a
prediction from that data.
We've been working with--
like I said--
Plumber and Vetiver
or those types of things
where we can deploy that.
And those get deployed to our
Posit Connect server.
The software stuff
happens mostly as a
collaborative effort between us
and our technology
folks in Python.
But another thing that we've
had a lot of success with
is when we're doing more
of an analysis or helping somebody
maybe--
we've actually written a few
research pieces, mostly
internal research pieces in--
we've been using
Quarto quite a bit.
So Quarto is a very, very
useful tool to create documents
that are sort of very closely
interwoven
with the underlying data, and
that's been a
super useful tool.
And that kind of gets us out
of the business of emailing
spreadsheets and Word documents
and that type of stuff.
I much, much, much
prefer the pattern of
publishing a document, we
publish it to our Connect
server, and sharing
a link with somebody.
And then if I need to
update it, I can update it there.
And there's even some really
nice features that we've seen
about. Like you can
have the same code,
the same Quarto document
generating the web page
that someone's looking at,
and downloading it as a PDF. And the PDFs
look really nice so we've
had some really good success there.
- Awesome. I see there
was a question about
Git a bit earlier
here. Let me ask it.
I see there's a star there.
What resources, if any,
did you use to help your team
get on board with using Git?
Were you all pretty familiar
with it already or did anyone
on the team start learning
from the ground up?
- I would say we've been
learning from the ground up. And
I was thinking about
this recently that
I must have taken
10 different times--
like I said, all right, I'm
going to learn Git. And I go
take some sort of online
course and sort of learn the
fundamentals, and it never
stuck. I just was like,
I don't really
get this too much.
And it wasn't until
actually we were having
help from the folks in our
technology team on how to set
up our repos, what kind of
patters
do we use when we collaborate?
I just today was told
we were using a trunk-based approach
for when we do our
branches and merges so that
was kind of news to me.
But I would say none of it really
stuck until I was put in a position--
or I put myself in a position where
I had to use it. And then once I--
I mean, once we started
collaborating across the team and I--
that's when I really
saw the power of it.
Because I'm from a place--
before Git, I mean,
back in my day,
it was like you'd have
some code and then you'd--
if you needed to change it,
you just were praying
that it didn't break.
And if it broke, you
kind of were sitting there thinking,
oh boy, I hope I remember
what I did so I can undo it.
And it's really liberating
to not have that kind of--
be carrying around that mental
luggage all the time about what
have I changed over the last
two hours and could I recover
what I had before. So, I mean,
I'm a huge Git
advocate right now.
Like
there's a really
good paper out there,
good enough practices
for scientific computing.
I think Jenny Bryant who's
a Posit employee is a co-author
of that thing. And
that's a really good--
she also has a
Git for R, I think,
or something like that
or some book like that.
- Yeah,
there's a lot of love for that
resource in the chat right now too,
Happy Git
with R.
- Happy Git with
R, yeah, that's the one.
And that's like even nowadays
if I'm doing something and I'm
not collaborating with
anyone and I'm in our studio,
I'm starting up a
new project, I mean,
I'm clicking that Git repo
button every time because that's like--
that's my safety net.
So I'd say I don't
have, really--
I mean,
we were lucky we had people
in our organization that helped us
get over the hump, but
the best way to get
familiar with it is use it.
So it's kind of a catch 22, I think,
there.
- Quick question, what's your
background view right now?
Are you in New York
right now at the office?
- Yes. So I work in
Midtown, Manhattan.
So I have a view of the
East River out there.
And so I can see from--
if I go that way,
I can see the 59th Street
Bridge and then over there I
can see the United
Nations building.
- Nice. I was just in
New York yesterday,
I should have came
by the office.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, did you
see any of the lights?
- I did, yeah,
it was beautiful.
- Nice, nice. Yeah,
I'm walking distance over to Saks
and the tree and stuff so
the other day I walked over
there, it's really cool.
- Cool.
Shoot, I should have
checked. I was right there.
I got to meet with Russ
who's usually in the hangouts too.
Let's see, let
me jump over to--
oh, Michael, you had a
question in the chat.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Sure, if you're
talking about me.
- Yes.
- Hi. Michael Thomas.
I'm also do a lot of data
science work in the financial
services space, particularly
in risk management.
So I was really excited to
hear from you today, Matt.
I appreciate it.
I was wondering if you
use Shiny apps at all to
communicate results of
Monte Carlo, simulations,
or stress testing
and things like that and how that's gone--
if at all--
to presenting those types
of results to non-technical folks
specifically.
- Yeah, we do use Shiny.
One of the things that
I get a little bit nervous
about with Shiny is like it's
such an amazing tool.
I would say that we've kind of
limited our use of that to more
of the model development piece.
So when we're building a model
and we want to communicate to
the users or the model
owners or the subject matter experts,
the people who know the
stuff, like, how this model works.
If I put in this input,
what kind of output--
what kind of
sensitivities am I seeing.
Shiny has been a really
great tool for that,
my concern about Shiny is if
I build something that is super awesome--
which is really
accessible with Shiny.
You can build really amazing
things. My concern would be that
I don't view myself as
like somebody who writes production code.
So if it were to become part
of a core part of people's
day to day lives,
I'd get nervous about something
along the lines of getting a
call at 11:00 PM that the
Shiny app is down and,
can you fix it, Matt?
And I'm the only guy
who knows how to fix it.
So it's like a bit of a
double edged sword so we do try to
really leverage our technology teams
when it comes to building core
functionality, software
functionality that people need.
So it's like with great
power comes great responsibility type
of a message I'm saying there.
But we've had great success
with Tiny. I think it's--
Shiny--
it's a really great tool
but mostly in the prototyping and
early result stage,
I would say. Yeah.
- Do you hand-- MICHAEL
THOMAS: I hear that.
No, thank you.
- I'm sorry.
Do you hand it over to
that team as an APIs?
Is that the workflow you
were talking about earlier?
- So, yeah, we would try to--
if that model we
would either try to--
I mean, we haven't really fully
executed on this vision but we
would be looking to deploy the
model as an API
and then allow--
reduce the bar of accessibility to
people there so that they could--
if they wanted to
perform some analysis,
they could kind of
do it themselves.
Or the other path would be
like try to work with technology to
build some sort of software that would be
in our
stable of software internally,
built software that people are
using to get things done. Yeah.
- Thank you.
Allan, I see you had a
question. You want to jump in here?
ALLAN: Yeah. Hi.
Matt, this is a super
naive question about the industry.
And I'm curious about how the work
that you do translates over to what
the analysts are
taking to customers.
And I'm assuming that
there's something that differentiates like
that's your value proposition for,
like our analysis is better
because you've got
competitors in the industry.
And so I wonder if you
can just give some context to, what
makes a report successful to
you and to your customers?
And how do you--
how
does that factor into how do
you plan an analysis or how do
you plan a model?
You can come at any
way that is useful. Just wondering,
how does this data fit into
the big picture of what your
customers are looking for?
- Sure.
I mean, that's a good question.
So
the way our business works is we
have a lot of different ratings teams,
so all of those teams are sort
of experts in their field.
There's a whole bunch of
different types of things that
we're rating. So we
rate corporates, we rate banks.
And then there's this whole
other side of the fence where
it's like people
issue debt that are--
that's backed by
some sort of cash
generating assets.
So that's called
structured finance.
So like residential mortgage backed
securities is a thing out there,
commercial mortgage
backed securities.
So each one of those things
has its team of subject matter
experts that are
in charge of doing
the credit analysis.
They know all about
what drives the credit,
what could make the credit not
pay. They know all that stuff.
So
each one of those groups have
one or more, I think we call
them methodologies.
So these are public statements
to the world that describe
everything that goes into--
it's kind of like the playbook. It's
not as sort of step one, two, three,
it's not like a recipe book
but if you know the industry,
you could pick that thing up and
you would have a sense of what is--
how do we do it? What
are we thinking about when we--
and I say we--
our company, KBRA,
does a credit rating.
So
the models we build are
generally like a component of
that. So we will build--
there's qualitative,
quantitative aspects of
the process, and our
work flows into the quantitative
piece of that. But it's
all part of a broader thing.
So I would say that KBRA
differentiates itself with like we have-- like
I said--
really strong credit rating
experts who do the work.
And they do quite extensive
write ups on everything, every
consideration they have when
they're creating the ratings. So
hopefully that
helps illustrate a little
bit of what's going on there.
ALLAN: Yeah, yeah,
it does. Thank you. MATT
MCDONALD: Yeah.
- Matt, I remember--
I'm thinking back to our
conversation at the Posit conference.
And we were talking a bit
about how you collaborate with
business users or people
that primarily use Excel
company.
And I was wondering if you
could expand a little bit on
that and share how you've
been able to, I guess, effectively
collaborate with
business users.
- Yeah.
Well, we have
experimented a little bit with
writing
VBA code that we can
share with people that would
allow them, give them access
to in a non-programmatic way
to an API. If I were to give--
if I were to publish the
best API in the world,
I think there's probably
80% to 90% of the people who
I work with just it
wouldn't be particularly helpful for them
because they don't know
how to interact with that.
There is quite a bit of--
it's always a
decision to be made--
I mean, we do--
I've done some work where I've
implemented my model in Excel, and
that's OK too. So I think
JD Long did the keynote speech
at the Posit conf last--
I don't know when
it was recently. And
he's a big advocate of
being mindful and empathetic for
people because,
ultimately, people,
they're just trying to do their
job and they just want to get
things done. And my job
is to try to help them.
So it's definitely a
challenge, though, because
what I do really want
to maintain some sort of
line
between my work and their work.
And I don't really
want to become their
Excel support
line type person. So
that's kind of a thing I'm
always trying to balance.
-
I see Tim you had a
question a bit earlier about internal packages,
but I see you might have a
few so feel free to pick your
favorite question.
TIM: Well,
you already answered
my question about internal
packages and another thing you
mentioned that you were writing
some internal packages.
The question I just
asked, though, is,
are you with a small team,
are you using large language
models like ChatGPT or things
like that to assist with
your code writing at all?
- Yeah. So we are--
I think that's in our future
and that's something I'm really eager to
engage with and have
that assistance with.
ChatGPT,
GitHub, Copilot
is a--
I've sort of dabbled with
at home. But
as an organization,
I think there are some
security concerns.
We don't generally like to--
we--
I mean, we are dealing
with sometimes non-public
information so we are very
locked down.
TIM: Yeah, I work
at a law firm so
I feel your pain.
We have our own
version of ChatGPT hosted in Azure
that's just for us so I'm--
I will tell you,
it is so much better
at writing rockagen comments for functions
for a package than
I ever could be.
- Oh, I can't wait.
We have not
yet engaged with that. That
sounds like an awesome,
awesome use case
of that technology.
Yeah, but we haven't
done that yet. And
I sit right next to the
head of security and
I'm talking to technology, and I
do think that at some point
everybody's going to have that
tool because if you don't,
then you're kind of just
not performing as well as your
competitors.
Yeah, we're just not there yet.
- I see Bill had a
question a bit earlier that was,
are you seeing more open source
being used in the financial industry?
- I mean,
we're using R and Python
and pretty much our entire
software--
internal software development teams
are using Python. So,
yeah, we're in favor
of Open Source, yeah.
- I guess maybe
it's also, like,
how have you seen it change over
the past eight years of being there too.
- I mean, so my company
was formed in 2010 and
I arrived in like 2015, so
it was definitely like a startup
mentality. So I would say
at that time,
it
was a little bit about just
get just get the job done
however you need to.
I'd say that we are
getting more and more--
as we grow,
our control framework is
maturing and we're getting more
and more controls in
place. But that hasn't
prevented us from engaging
with Open Source in any way.
- Julia, I see you had
another question around
what happens when you're
done with the model.
Do you want to jump in here?
JULIA: Yeah,
you were talking earlier about how
Shiny for you is mostly a
piloting tool and also that
you've been trying to put
things behind,
for example, API.
Like you put a very, very
API app for a model. And my
question is mostly,
what is it that actually
consumes the models that you build?
Do you have your IT
built some infrastructure around that or
is--
will there be like a
batch job that gets run?
How does your model then
blob out?
- I think I would say that
we have not yet standardized
everything to the point where I can say
we always do X, Y or Z. So
it's been
IT will
incorporate our models into
their software that they're
building. Like I said,
sometimes we
embed ourselves in the
technology team and
put a hat on as a software
developer to write the portion
of the code that does--
that implements the model.
Sometimes
we've implemented our models
with the worksheet functions
and they're completely done in
Excel. So there's no real--
what I'm trying to do is to
standardize things
to the point, like,
I would love to be in a position
where if I were to deploy an API,
then
everybody in the company would have
access to it without a huge
hurdle to overcome.
Just starting to look
at the chat here.
- Yeah, it can be
overwhelming to try
and talk at the same time but
I'll send it to you so you can
read it after too.
But I did just share in
the chat we did have a recent
event. I'm losing track of
time, maybe this was last week.
But it was a really
helpful machine learning workflow that
Gordon Shotwell from
our team went through.
So I just put it in the
chat if anyone wants to check it out.
I feel like this conversation
was just reminding me
of a lot of what talked about.
- Yeah. I will say
that so, you know, I
love the work that Max Kuhn
and Julia have been doing with the
tidymodels suite.
And when Julia started talking
about Vetiver and model
deployment and
model monitoring,
it was really heartening to
see that other people were thinking
about that stuff as well.
Because that's like you could
build the model and you could--
and your job's not done. Your
job's like way far from done.
You have to figure
out how to get people,
how to allow people
to use your model. And
that's a big
tough nut to crack.
- So how do we get
people to use it?
- Oh, well, so, like I said,
sometimes we make it work in
Excel, sometimes we deploy an API,
and sometimes we become
software engineers and start
making commits to a Git repo.
-
I guess I'm thinking too like
about the communication part of it. How
do you work with them to help
people see the value in some of
the models or do they
see that initially?
- Yeah,
well, I mean, I would love to
solve all of the problems
I currently have and put myself
in a position to start
generating more internal
business for myself by
convincing people to trust
their models more and
use
them more and more and more.
But we kind of are dealing
with the problem in front of us
right now, I would say, yeah.
- Another question I saw just
pop into the chat, Phil asked,
in your organization,
do you have to justify or
submit for approval to an IT or
regulatory group?
- I mean, yeah.
I mean, we have a--
it's a whole thing.
So we need to
describe the project we're making and
then that goes where we're proposing.
And then that goes into a
prioritization decision making
type of a thing.
I mean, it's not quite as
formalized as other places I've
seen. So it's not like
I'm filling out like Form
T95
or anything like
that. But there is--
I mean, we, obviously--
I mean, we're a
business, right, so we
need to work on the things
that are most important
to us. Yeah, so definitely. But
I'm sort of lucky that
I've been here for quite
some time. A lot of the--
I'd say that early
on while I was here,
a lot of what I was doing was
work to gain people's trust,
and that's a super
important thing.
And
not to pat myself on the back
too hard but I did it right.
I have worked hard to make sure
that people can trust me. So like
this most--
we just recently kicked off a
new project where it's more of
that software development type of
a lane that we're getting into.
And that one for a
long time I was really
trying to figure out how do I
do this job. I don't want to be--
I'm not a software developer,
but I kind of play
one on TV sometimes.
How do I do this job where
I can keep a low profile
and do things autonomously?
And I concluded that
there are certain things that
you do need to get in the
queue, get in that
prioritization sort of game,
and that's the best--
that's going to be
the best outcome.
Because you don't really
want to be creating in an
organization like a shadow IT
or organization or
anything like that.
I think
that it's great for getting things
done but I think down the line,
we pay a lot of people who
really know a lot about
technology to do that job.
I don't want to have
another one of those
run by a handful
of people I have
that become really important. So
I'd rather be on their turf.
-
Are there questions that you'd like
to ask the group here or
things that you'd love to
maybe open up to more of a
discussion on? I'm trying to
think back to something we
were talking about at the conference
as well and we were at.
- I hadn't really
contemplated that.
I thought you guys were
going to ask me questions.
- Right, no, I can
keep going on this,
I just wanted to make sure
that if there are certain
problems that you're facing
that you're just curious to
open up to ask everybody here,
that we give the time
for that as well.
- Yeah.
If somebody has any good ideas
after hearing what we're dealing with.
I mean, a lot of the
difficulties
we've encountered being
in this role between
the credit rating analysts
who are doing their job,
they want to rate--
they want to do the credit
analysis and technology who's
also doing their job is that
it really opened us up to
being just people not really
understanding what our role is.
So lots of times we
really do get confused with technology.
Like we'll get a call from--
I'll get a call from
senior leadership,
people who are very senior
in the company, and say like,
I need this thing
that does X, Y, and Z.
And they're not
describing a model,
they're not describing
like really anything
I do or I'm really good at.
So
that sort of establishing--
like trying to continually
hammer home like what--
describe to people
what is it that--
what would you say you do here.
That's something that
I've sort of encountered a lot,
that clarity and making
sure that people understand that.
And then just that idea of
trying to really--
because we are a smaller
team and we do have limited
resources, just establishing
those lines of ownership
and helping people without
doing their job is kind of
a thing that can be difficult too.
So those are things that
kind of need to be managed,
I would say. And
that's what a lot of--
I wouldn't say I spent a lot of
time on it but I've spent a lot
of time thinking
about it in the past.
A lot of the things
we've done around
using the right tools to
get our work repeatable and this
type of thing and being able
to engage with technology on their
turf in certain instances
has really been beneficial.
- I see a lot
of great questions jumping into--
or coming into the chat here.
Laura, do you want to
ask your question here?
LAURA: Sure.
I'm going to stay off camera
because I'm a little under the weather.
So my question is,
have there ever been
situations where a rating
against maybe a portfolio or a
company has come out
against what the gut check
is? I'm always interested in those
situations where an analysis
goes against the initial
hypothesis and how
organizations handle that.
So I wonder if you have
some situations and how you've navigated those.
- Yeah. I mean,
I would say that we--
I mean,
none of our ratings are
like the model spits out the
ratings, and that's what we
go with. So it's always--
there's always a level of
human oversight and human
intervention
there, I would say.
I mean, obviously,
with any model you're going
to have some outcome that somebody
who really knows the
domain is going to say,
no, I don't think
that's the deal.
I don't think that's
what it is. But
our methodologies
really accommodate
for that. These are--
there's always a
qualitative and quantitative component.
And, ultimately, the
way the process works,
there's a rating committee and the
decision is made not by my
model. My model is an
input into that process.
Part of the reason why we--
earlier I said we rely--
given the choice between a
model whose accuracy ratio is
1% greater than
this other model,
that I can explain to somebody
how this model got this answer.
I'm pretty much always going
to go with the explainability part.
And your question
is kind of like--
is part of the reason for that.
Is like if I get a question,
why did the model
give me this answer?
I'm very happy to explain to
them, and then that could drive
a conversation about the
limitations of the model.
Maybe that would be an
indication that maybe it's time--
maybe this model
has exceeded its utility
and we need to build a--
re-estimate it, build a
new one that has other
risk drivers in it.
Those types of things.
So it definitely happens.
We're never really put in
a position where something goes
out the door that sort of came
out of model and nobody looked at.
- RM,
I see you have a question in the chat
as well if you want to ask this next.
RM: Yeah. Hi. Thanks.
Small question.
If I understand your
organization correctly, I'm
trying to understand whether you
consider yourself to be a
embedded within the business units
or more of a centralized
operation for your
data science work.
- Yeah, we're a centralized
function, a support
function really.
And then more on a project
type basis would we consider
ourselves embedded
with a team. So
if we're working on a project
and we need to have the subject
matter experts in the room,
then we're all in that way.
So on a project basis
maybe we would become embedded,
but we're never truly embedded
because we don't
run the models and
we're not really
engaged in that rating process
on the ground so much.
So one thing, always
quantitative and qualitative
part of the model--
maybe I misspoke. I
meant like the rating
process or the rating--
the analysis
is what I maybe
should have said.
- I think we have time for
a few more questions here.
But Allan, I see you had
another question in the chat.
Want to jump in?
ALLAN: Yeah, sure. Thanks.
I'm curious, Matt,
you mentioned at one point
having things that you want to
do. You want to develop
products that you want to develop.
And I'm curious what the
balance is of things like that
where you get to be
entrepreneurial versus--
and that goes into some kind
of portfolio of prioritization
that I think a lot of
us are kind of familiar with conceptually--
versus things that come into
your team from the businesses
or from other customers. How
do you balance those things?
What kind of help
do you have in picking
when to do one
versus the other?
- Yeah,
I mean, this is
getting back to that idea of
we employ some of the tools that
are available to technology. So
we have a support mailbox,
that's the quantitative
modeling support mailbox.
So if somebody has a question
or something that they want us
to work on, they send a--
they send an email there.
It automatically creates a
Jira ticket. And we manage--
we use Jira to manage our work.
We do maintain workflow limits,
so we don't really want people
working on more than two or
three things at a time.
And so far it's worked.
We really haven't had this--
that sort of like a
moment of like, oh,
do I do this really
important thing or that really important
thing? We've been able to use
that to help us not only like
not forget to do things--
which is a huge
benefit--
but manage our workload.
But it also gets back to that
idea of building trust. So
I've been lucky that
I've had the opportunity to
do things that are--
had that overlap between stuff
that my company needs to get
done and stuff that I'm
interested in doing.
So that's been really good. And
it's been nice to be able to
call the shots along the way.
ALLAN: Nice. Thanks.
- Geoffrey just put a
question to the chat.
How does your team
work together?
Do you have a data engineer
that pulls data, passes
the data scientist,
or does that--
the person that creates the model
do it all or something else?
- Yeah, I mean, it really is
on a project by project basis,
that sort of the genesis of
what that data set looks like.
Sometimes the team who's responsible
for the rating have some--
have access to really great data
sets that we can use to
build our models.
Sometimes it's about
pulling it together from
publicly available
sources like the
Federal Reserve economic database
or other types of
things, and pulling that
together. I will say that--
I did neglect to say we do have
embedded on our team like a
folks who are that
MLOps type role.
So they're more technologists who
are helping us maintain our platform.
And also there are crackerjack
coders who could sort step in
and give us some feedback
on how to do things,
how to make Git work better and
also how to engage with some of
the internal resources
and technology.
So we do have some folks on
the team who are more of that
technology role who are
helping us get things done.
And sometimes they'll be
useful in that sort of data--
more the upfront
data acquisition.
- I know we talked a little
bit about trust or came up a few
times, and I was just wondering
what are some of those ways
you were able to build trust with
the stakeholders.
- Yeah.
I'd say like early on--
and it was--
I used the Shiny app to get
it done. So early on I was--
this was before when I
was doing the model validation
stuff. So I kind of had--
I was starting to
get insights into,
what are the sensitivities?
What are driving this model?
How does this thing
actually work?
And I had just learned Shiny so I was like,
I took that knowledge and I
sort of built a Shiny app that
allowed people to move
a slider, press the button,
see the graph type of stuff.
And I would say that people's
socks were knocked off.
They were blown away.
So those types of moments
are not just useful in--
for--
because now they have
something that they can look at
the sensitivity but
from a more personal
perspective,
suddenly people were
saying like, oh,
Matt kind of seems to know
how to get things done.
Maybe we should trust him.
So I think it's looking
for those types of opportunities,
and it's never like--
there's no playbook there.
It's just you have to keep your
head up and you got to know your--
know what you're capable
of and deliver. And
that's really useful.
- Love it. That's great.
If people want to get
connected with you, Matt,
is the best place LinkedIn?
- Yeah, LinkedIn is
good. LinkedIn is good.
- Awesome. Well, I did just
want to remind everybody that we did--
I think this was probably
five weeks ago now,
but we had a
lengthy conversation on how to
estimate the ROI for a data
project. And there were so many
thoughts on this and
conversations in the chat that
we decided we wanted to have
a separate follow up conversation on that.
And so
I shared that in the chat
a bit earlier if anybody wants
to add it to their calendar.
Let me try and
copy it over again.
But that's going to be on
December 13. So it's on a
Wednesday. And it's just
like a bonus Data
Science
Hangout chat for us.
Let me see. Here it is.
Copy my message from
above and put it there.
But I'd love to have
you all join us on that.
If it's something that was of
interest to you when we talked
about it before, feel free
to add it to your calendar.
But thank you so much,
Matt, for joining us.
- Thank you for hosting.
I really enjoyed it.
Thank you so much.
- Yeah, thank you.
Well, have a great
rest of the day.
We actually
think only have
one more Data Science
Hangout for 2023. So that will
be next week before we take our
holiday break for the hangout.
So hope to see you
all back next week. Thanks, everybody.
- Bye. RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: Bye.